what is this reality all about like what  are we what do you think we're here for  you're coming you're coming in hot with  the easy questions the podcast is called  pretty intense this qualifies as a  pretty intense question I I guess I  would say we're here to  have experiences grow from those  experiences and then figure out how to  contribute to a better world it's an  interesting time because we have access  to so many tools to help us become  better happier more fulfilled Etc but we  also have a culture  I think in certain ways coddles us and  tells us that the recipe for happiness  is comfort and luxury and material  accumulation and we've diluted ourselves  into thinking this will make us happy  but I think this is moving us further  and further apart from happiness